for those fans who are eagerly and
impatiently awaiting the new Fantastic 4
MCU Reboot film like myself great news
for you today as the Director Matt
shakman has offered us a really great
update and if you've been worried that
the MCU might not get the new Fantastic
4 movie right well hopefully what Matt
shakman says in this interview calms you
down a little bit and gives you some
hope and excitement so let's dive into
this awesome and fantastic FC pun
intended update about the Fantastic 4
from the Fantastic 4 director himself
Matt shakman where he talks about the
future film also if you're new be sure
to subscribe to the channel so you don't
miss out on any of the latest MCU news
and if you subscribe and leave a comment
you're automatically entered in our
giveaway for a chance to win a PS5 an
Xbox series X some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items the winner gets to pick
one item and we pick one winner at the
end of each month so upcoming MCU
Fantastic 4 Reboot film director Matt
shakman was recently on the discourse
podcast where he was interviewed by host
Mike D'Angelo now he was there to talk
about Monarch Legacy of Monsters the
upcoming Apple TV series which he's an
executive producer for and also directs
a couple of the episodes but of course
you cannot interview Matt shakman right
now without asking him about the
Fantastic 4 and keep in mind that Matt
shakman also directed ju division so the
first thing that he was asked is if Matt
shakman was in talks with Marvel Studios
about doing anything else between One
Division and the Fantastic 4 and he said
no it's just about Fantastic 4 yeah I
love that comic I certainly let them
know that I love that comic I think John
Watts was on it for a while and he would
have done a fantastic job but he moved
on and I was thrilled that I was able to
jump into the director's chair on it and
take his place so of course for those
who didn't know John Watts who directed
Spider-Man no way home Spider-Man fire
from home Spider-Man homecoming the
entire Trilogy John Watts was originally
supposed to direct the Fantastic 4 film
and Marvel Studios had announced this
however he kind of needed a break from
Superhero films and that's
understandable he did direct the three
MCU Spider-Man films and of course we
all know how big Spider-Man no way home
was and especially with all the leaks
and everything going down one can see
how he would need a break so Marvel
Studios asked Matt shakman and it sounds
like they asked him because he was such
a big fan of the Fantastic 4 and knows
the comic stories which is great because
we know Kevin fige is putting a lot of
love into this and they need a director
who is going to do the same and he goes
on to talk about the cast now he doesn't
reveal it here but it definitely sounds
like he has already picked the cast him
and fogy have decided who they want to
play Marvel's first family and it sounds
like they really really did take their
time and made sure the casting was
perfect here's what he said I'm thrilled
that people are as passionate about
these characters as I am the fact that
there is so much debate I love it I have
been thinking thinking about who should
play these characters before I had the
job to direct the movie and I understand
why everybody would be thinking in the
same way chemistry is super important
it's Marvel's first family I have to get
it right I have to get that chemistry
right and then he said as far as a
casting announcement is concerned he
said it's not going to be immediately
when the SAG strike has been resolved
but we'll be able to share some news at
some point and I hope people are as
excited about this cast as I am so it
definitely sounds like right there like
the cast really is locked in confirmed
done deal they have decided who they
want those actors have agreed probably
just verbally right now but then after
the SAG strike ends they can officially
get back to business cross the te's dot
the eyes and sign official contracts to
lock in that cast and then they could
announce it and this is why he's
probably saying it's not going to come
immediately when the strike ends like as
soon as they announce the strike is
officially over then they come out and
announce the cast They probably can't do
that because they need to sign the
official contracts once the strike is
over so hopefully once the strike ends
we'll get to know who the official cast
is maybe a couple of weeks or a few
weeks after and here's where some fans
can be put a little bit at ease because
a lot of people have been wondering with
all of the changes going on over at
Marvel Studios right now all of the
firings they've been doing and script
changes and complete scrapping of shows
and starting over from the beginning
we're talking about Daredevil born again
with all of that going on some fans
might have been wondering how the
Fantastic 4 is doing however Matt
shackman confirms that despite all of
that going on the Fantastic 4 is doing
great when asked if Marvel's recent
troubles have had an effect on the
development of the Fantastic 4 he
responded with it hasn't we'll break
down exactly what he said but first big
thank you to hellofresh for sponsoring
this video many of you probably know by
now that I personally use hellofresh a
lot because for me it's simply makes
sense I have a pretty busy schedule in
my day-to-day life and hellofresh just
makes eating good meals a lot easier for
me with over 40 different recipes that I
could choose from each week hellofresh
does all the shopping and meal planning
for you ingredients arrive at your
doorstep pre-portioned and ready to cook
along with pictured step-by-step recipe
cards they literally make it as easy as
it possibly could be the meals are very
quick to make and they do include some
15minute meals as well it takes the
hassle out of meal time but it also can
save you money hellofresh is cheaper
than grocery shopping and 25% less
expensive than takeout that means less
stress of worrying about what you're
going to eat and you save money so if
interested go to hellofresh.com
Cosmic and use code 50 Cosmic for 50%
off plus free shipping that's
hellofresh.com
Cosmic and use code 50 Cosmic for 50%
off plus free shipping so again when
asked if all of the complications over
at Marvel Studios have affected the
Fantastic 4 he responded with it hasn't
he then went on to say I mean we've been
on our process consistently I've been on
the project for a little over a year and
working away hard at it the way we'd
work on any film at Marvel and certainly
the way we worked on One Division which
is starting with you know what is the
story we want to tell what is the theme
of the story why are we telling the
story and just developing then the best
possible version of that story and how
do we want to bring these characters to
life so you know in terms of outside
influence or conversations it hasn't
really been a factor it's always high
stakes you always have to get it right
so that's great to know with everything
happening over at Marvel Studios right
now all of the changes that they are
making none of that is happening or
affecting the development of the
Fantastic 4 but then Matt shackman went
on to talk about the story and how it's
going to be pretty original and they're
not just going to take a story from the
comics and adapt it but rather just get
influence from the comics and make their
own story he said in the interview the
idea that I've loved so much about
Marvel is that we're not just going to
take a run that exists and translate it
to film we're going to do what every
great run has done which is stand on the
shoulders of what came before but then
think about how we as artists living in
this moment processing what we're all
processing What story do we want to tell
right now that feels true to us as
people and that is informed though by
everything that's coming before so it
sounds like what they're going to do is
kind of just have all of the information
about all of the Fantastic Four stories
that there's been get inspiration from
that but also get inspiration from the
previous Fantastic Four films that we've
seen hopefully just the really good
parts not the really bad parts and the
bad movie but put all of that together
and talk about how they could create a
great story that would fit in the MCU
right now and another really cool thing
is that he says he consults with Matt
fraction a lot Matt that fraction of
course has written many Fantastic Four
stories so the fact that he is bouncing
ideas off of one of the comic writers
for the Fantastic 4 is simply amazing as
well overall it sounds like they are
treating the Fantastic 4 movie with a
lot of passion and a lot of care making
sure that they truly get this movie
right so hopefully this video makes you
feel better if you had some concerns
about whether all of the changes at
Marvel Studios that are happening right
now were affecting the Fantastic 4
hopefully your mind is at ease now and
if you wondering if they were going to
be super passionate about this hopefully
this answered it for you and makes you
feel more calm so let us know your
thoughts about all of this in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe of course you
can also find us on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof
woof